madame monsieur bonsoir les enfants de
dieu secte dissoute en 88 mais
rebaptisée et famille d'amour avait
aussi élu domicile dans la région et
c'était à condrieu l'information à
percer dans le cadre d'une vaste enquête
commencée en 91 à aix en provence et qui
a abouti hier à l'interpellation de 50
personnes en tout dont neuf pour notre
région au sud de lyon la communauté
n'avait jamais fait parler d'elle mais
elle est soupçonnée d'incitation de
mineurs à la débauche
c'est dans cette maison à condrieu que
neuf adultes et 34 enfants tous mineurs
sauf un ont été interpellés hier matin
par la gendarmerie ses membres de la
secte famille d'amour ex enfant de dieu
il est ici depuis deux ans et demi
tranquillement chefs d'inculpation
invoquée par le juge aixois affaire de
moeurs prostitution incitation à la
débauche pédophilie mauvais traitements
enfants le propriétaire de la maison lui
même n'en reviens m'en sortir je dis
tout de suite puisque chaque fois j'ai
vu j'ai vu des gosses tout ça et là pas
bêtement l'autre absolument en forme
physique maintenant
l'intérieur de la caravane située
derrière la maison foisonne de lecture
et objets symboliques et atteste d'un
prosélytisme actif dirigée surtout vers
les enfants cette carte postale en
témoigne j'ai appris le nouveau langage
car dieu m'a donné une jolie fille nous
sommes déjà dans la même chambre nous
prions pour vous tous les jours quan les
principes d'éducation sont la lecture de
la bible et l'amour du prochain
le gourou moïse prêcher puisque le
christ a offert sa vie à l'humanité les
femmes peuvent offrir leur corps si les
faits les faits sont avérés c'est c'est
l'indignation parce que c'est si ces
pratiques sont son sont réels on est
tout de même au fond de l'abjection que
deux lignes au mur les membres de
famille d'amour à condrieu sont français
américains canadiens turc et cetera on
ne leur connaît pas de profession si ce
n'est celle de missionnaire selon leurs
propres termes
aujourd'hui et 34 enfants sont
recueillis par la cité de l'enfance de
bron les adultes sont en garde à vue
jusqu'à demain dont la tante
d'éventuelles mises en examen par le
juge d'instruction